ever since the ancient Greeks discovered
cosmetics a word my dad says they
invented by the way every little girl
tries on some of her mother's lipstick
so do many little boys cosmetics today
are only a part of a makeup kit our film
makeup artists rely on a variety of
products to beautify or uglify as the
script demands - stirring examples of
each are present in the two films
nominated for the best of the complex
art here are the nominees for
achievement in makeup John Jackson and
Beatrice de alva for their work in the
colorful tale of painter Frida Kahlo in
Frieda John M Eliot jr. and Barbara
Lorenz for their time-traveling work in
the classic HG Wells story of the time
machine and the Oscar goes to John
Jackson and Beatrice de Alba for freedom
this is the first Academy Award a
nomination for John Jackson and Beatrice
de Alba
you
Wow uh thank you the Academy this indeed
a mind-blowing experience and we like it
thank you to Salma none of us would have
been there without you Alma Molina may
your salary on the next one be bigger
than the entire budget on this one
Alfred Molina for being our champion
Julie Taymor for her vision and her
incredible ability to convey it judy
chin our department market head who
should have been up with us tonight
without your work duty we wouldn't even
be here tonight none of us expected to
be nominated or to even get all this
recognition for our work through all my
sweat and tears we just wanted to give
some of her dream and then we fell in
love thank you
will the owner of a 1972 El Camino with
a dent in the left fender and a broken
sideview mirror oh my god this is too
sad to go on
our next presenter has the same name as
the actor who played the original James
Bond here Sean Connery
oscar has had great reason to celebrate
over the years there have been so many
remarkable performances given by
actresses supporting roles